alors ils ont évidemment lu votre livre
avec beaucoup d'intérêt ils ont des
questions à vous poser on va commencer
par damien oui c'est vrai j'ai lu votre
livre avec beaucoup d'intérêt néanmoins
ce qui m'a surpris dans ce livre
finalement c'est que vous conseiller aux
fans quasiment systématiquement de se
justifier voire même parfois de
s'excuser alors je vais vous donner
quelques exemples
lors de l'annoncé de la grossesse à
l'employeur vous préconisez que la femme
doit prendre des pincettes pour éviter
de le froisser normal il va devoir
trouver un remplaçant dans un autre
registre vous préconisez aussi vous
donner cette astuce à une femme qu'elle
doit par exemple organiser une fête en
interne pour justement mettre au courant
c'est qu'au laquelle vont partir et je
ne parle même pas du faire-part de
naissance que vous demandez également
d'envoyer à toutes les collègues alors
ma question est la suivante est ce que
ce n'est pas quelque part un peu anti
féministe et culpabilisant de demander
aux femmes de se justifier alors qu'on
pourrait légitimement et bien partir du
principe qu'une grossesse est normal et
qu' il faut l'accepter comme tel
complètement je suis bien d'accord avec
vous non non au contraire fin moi
justement tout mon discours ça a
toujours été depuis la création à mon
travail
désir deux choses la première c'est que
vous fait comme on peut et la deuxième
c'est que l'idée est le but de ce guide
est de tout le réseau à mon travail
c'est de trouver justement ce qui est
fait pour nous c'est pas parce qu'on a
une voisine super carriériste ou une
belle mère qui est s'est épanoui en
étant mère au foyer qu'on doit faire
commettre au contraire tout le message
inverse après parfois avec un petit peu
de diplomatie sa masse mieux donc
effectivement si avant de revenir aux
boules on envoyait ainsi faire part
sympa de l'essence ou fait une baby
shower
cool je pense que c'est effectivement ça
fait mieux passé 'l'annonce mais
effectivement vous avez raison le
rappeler c'est toujours une bonne
nouvelle mais pour autant à chaque fois
vous nous expliquer et c'est ce qu'on
voit à travers de tous les exemples qui
sont dans l'ombre âge c'est qu'à chaque
fois il faut faire mieux passer
l'information et oui comme s'il y avait
tout de même des pincettes à prendre
parce que par définition et de façon
intrinsèque on est des femmes et donc il
ya des éléments minéraux ont fait d'être
femme mais complètement il ya toujours
des difficultés je veux dire on peut
vivre dans un monde irréel de bisounours
idéal où on va dire ah non parce que
c'est illégal
ça va pas être fait par exemple les
entre ces embauches il suffirait de dire
bah c'est illégal on n'a pas le droit de
vous demander si vous allez avoir des
enfants quelle est votre mode de garde
donc on n'en parle pas mais dans la
vraie vie du quotidien ce que tous les
maires dit c'est qu'en fait non ce droit
il n'est pas appliqué et ça c'est tout
le travail qu'on mène au gouvernement de
faire en sorte justement d'appliquer
réellement le droit complètement et
d'aller vérifier ma collègue la ministre
je travaille elle a multiplié par sept
les contrôles de l'inspection du travail
sur la question de l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes
mais derrière parfois
avec des petites astuces et des petits
conseils ça peut passer plus
tranquillement avec - conflit dont
l'idée c'est aussi que ça passe bien
d'éviter d'éviter un conflit frontal
oui c'est vrai vous le disiez
effectivement et c'est totalement inégal
mais parfois lors d'un entretien
d'embauché moi vous demandez au détour
d'une question faussement and war in
faith vous êtes dans quelle situation
familiale et c'est que vous avez un
amoureux etc etc
et c'est la piscine de juste répondu
cette question est illégal je ne sais
pas répond n'a pas le boulot y'a pas un
héros du tout pour le coup caroline a
également une telle oui alors ça c'est
avant l'accouchement mais après
l'accouchement aujourd'hui en france
encore une femme elle paye très cher le
fait d'avoir un ou pire deux enfants
c'est dire que quand elle revient c'est
compliqué son retour elle est évidemment
moins payé qu'un homme est ce qu'un jour
on va arriver à une parité entre voilà
des femmes qui ont des enfants et qui en
droit d'en avoir et des hommes qui
travaillent au même niveau que nous avec
mon placement d'ailleurs c'est hyper
intéressant ce que vous dites parce que
dans la loi théoriquement quand on
revient d'un congé maternité
on est censé avoir une augmentation
égale à la moyenne des augmentations qui
ont été octroyés à poste équivalent dans
le service pendant le congé maternité
or il ya assez peu de maires qui le
savent il ya parfois des employeurs qui
ne le savent pas donc ça fait partie des
critères de l'index d'égalité
professionnelle que le gouvernement a
mis en place pour justement que ce
combat sedan droits formels théorique à
un droit réel donc ça c'est un
engagement fort qu'une part très